winter is coming and so am I after the
latest House of the Dragon season 2
trailer just dropped it's jam-packed
with dragony goodness I'm not sure if
that's even a word but who cares this is
your warning this video will have
spoilers from Fire and Blood but keep in
mind that the show doesn't always follow
the book so there will be some room for
interpretation I plan on covering the
entire season so if you like my analysis
be sure to drop a like And subscribe for
those of you who didn't like the time
jumps of season 1 don't worry executive
producer Ryan condle has said that
season 2 will play without any jumps
starting right where we left off at the
end of season 1 reir Targaryen has just
learned that her son luceros has been
killed after his parlay with house
Baratheon at storm Zen here we see the
black queen overlooking storm Zend
looking rather ragged I wouldn't be
surprised if the show has her going over
there to look for her son's body in the
book Luke's body is never found with one
wild story even claiming he made it to
shore alive but lost all his memory
spending the rest of his life as a
simple-minded fisherman through
voiceover we hear hand of the king Otto
high tower remark that errors were made
in the hours after King viserys's death
and no doubt we'll see how those errors
will lead to a chain of events that
affect the outcome of the story in many
wild and insane ways King aegon II
arrives to sit on the throne as those
around him pledge allegiance in the
aftermath of his takeover those loyal to
Queen rira were killed or locked away in
the dungeons other had to swear falty to
the new king notice these three
characters behind the king in this shot
we can make out two of them Lord Martin
rain a lord from house rain who are
subjects of House Lannister and Leon
estermont who is probably a lord too you
won't find them in the book they were
created specifically for the show these
younger Lords are allied with the greens
and my guess is that they are friends of
aegon here we see Damon targaryen's
iconic helmet after learning of Luke's
death he writes a letter from heren Hall
to the queen stating that lucerys must
be Avenged an eye for an eye a son for a
son apparently the title of episode one
is a son for a son Damon's letter will
prompt one of the most harrowing scenes
I've ever encountered in Martin's
writing which I'll simply refer to as
blood and cheese but I'll get to that in
a bit the dance of dragons the name of
the civil war between these two factions
features over 17 major battles OB
obviously HBO doesn't have the budget to
cover all of them so I'm guessing a lot
will be glossed over or combined here we
see soldiers from house high tower
marching to battle and autoc
contemplating by the fire Queen Allison
exclaims that many will die and look at
someone's hand holding a cane could that
be the club foot himself Lis strong I'm
just glad Allison's feet are away here's
our first look at Christen Cole with
markedly less hair and blood stains on
his armor it also looks like he's
wearing the hand hand of the king
necklace in the book Otto is removed as
aegon's hand in favor of the more
bloodthirsty Kristen Kristen here is
beheading someone and you'll notice
these soldiers still bear the Targaryen
sigil but this time in gold as to
separate itself from rira a ball spins
around the marble plate of the small
Council as we get this face off between
King Egon II seen here wearing King Egon
the first original crown and rira
wearing viserys's crown that was
smuggled out of the city by Eric cargle
in season 1 here's our first shot of a
character named Adam of Hull he'll
eventually go on to ride sea smoke who
has been riderless for over 6 years
after the departure of Reiner's husband
Lor Adam is considered a Dragon Seed a
bastard child with Valerian blood and
some say he's even the child of corus
Valyrian we're then treated to our first
shot at what appears to be the Battle of
rook's rest this is a major battle as it
sees the death of renise Targaryen and
her Dragon mise in addition King aegon
II is burned so bad in this fight he
becomes horribly disfigured and does not
rise from his bed for over a year
leaving aan the one eye as the deao king
in his stead we'll see a shot of him
looking at the throne perhaps
foreshadowing him eventually sitting on
it there are other shots of this battle
including Kristen riding through battle
and soldiers getting completely engulfed
in flames a shot of the black Council on
Dragonstone with Damon on the left reira
in the middle Reise on the right and a
Cargill behind here's Damon executing
someone in front of a godswood tree
we've seen one of these in the courtyard
of King's Landing the sky behind doesn't
quite look like the bright and saturated
kind we've seen at King's Landing but it
would be quite poetic if this is demon
executing Auto high tower in the book
it's never mentioned who executes uto
just that it was ordered by rira our
first and only shot of snow could we be
somewhere close to Winterfell at the end
of season 1 we know that renea's eldest
son Jay was sent to Winterfell to get
the allegiance of the Starks here's a
shot of Allison in front of a lake
potentially the God's eye she never
really leaves King's Landing once the
dance of dragons starts so it's possible
this is a dream check out reira here
with her Dragon Cyrax she's standing
across from what is most likely Adam of
Hull and sea smoke in the book ringer
has Adam arrested suspecting he's a
turncloak he escapes and Lord corus is
arrested for warning him so it looks
like the show could be leaning towards
this oress and his bastard children
narrative here's Queen Helena covered in
a Black Veil Reise tells rira that
there's no war so bloody as one between
dragons and this is followed by Baya
riding the dragon moondancer back at
King's Landing near the sept we'll see a
commotion involving Queen Allison this
is likely at the funeral of Prince Jaris
Aon II Nena's child who was murdered by
the Assassins blood and cheese we'll see
a brief shot of cheese here with Helena
these two men were ordered by Damon to
sneak into King's Landing and kill one
of the King's children as revenge for
aiman killing Luke and these two are
successful killing Jaris the people of
King's Landing look to be riding and
fleeing which could mean we're getting
close to when Queen rira takes back the
city a soldier of house Bracken unche
his sword the brackens swear themselves
to aegon and the greens a quick shot of
Damon at top his dragon crais and
Kristen beating the crap out of someone
now this shot has me really excited this
is Eric car fighting another Knight in
the book Eric's twin brother aric is
sent to Dragonstone to pose as Eric
since they're twins he could easily go
Behind Enemy Lines and kill rira or her
children but as luck would have it Eric
sees his brother posing as him and the
two battle to the death each of them
succumbing to their wounds here we have
aan a top vagar the largest and most
formidable of the Dragons you can see
how the soldiers basically stop in their
tracks as this she beast enters the
battlefield and and with that the
trailer comes to an end and we're giving
a summer 2024 start to the show I don't
know about you guys but I'm absolutely
pumped now I turn it over to you what
did you think of the trailer and what do
you think will happen in season 2 I want
to hear your thoughts and theories in
the comments below thanks for watching
be sure to like And subscribe and for
more bad takes you can follow me on
Twitter and Instagram at thinkstory YT
until next time remember Daddy loves you
very
much